good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it's been more than a
week since a California psychology
professor named Christine Ford accused
judge Brett Kavanaugh of committing some
form of sexual assault against her back
in 1982 they were both high school
students at the time
Ford's claim has stopped Cavanaugh a
Supreme Court nomination in place
Washington has been consumed by the
debate ever since a number of Senate
Republicans are said to be undecided on
the question of Cavanaugh's guilt or
innocence they say they'd like to hear
more from Christine Ford on Thursday
when she's scheduled to testify in the
Senate strikingly though not a single
Democrat remains undecided every one of
them plans to vote against Kavanagh
they've made up their minds they don't
need the evidence and now this wrinkle
tonight there are more allegations
consistent in many ways with the
allegations we have already heard
leading Democrats are calling these new
claims powerful compelling and highly
credible they are all but daring
Republicans to question the new accusers
the victims they say must be believed
here's a selection of the charges
oh just kidding that's a scene from the
crucible which you'll remember is the
Arthur Miller play about the Salem witch
trials Miller wrote the crucible back in
1953 that was a time when liberals still
cared about civil liberties and due
process and the right to face your
accuser Miller wrote it as an allegory
about the McCarthy hearings McCarthy
hearings were a period the left deeply
hated until they took power and
recreated it themselves nowadays you
weren't a progressives still read
Miller's play and if so are they
outraged by it maybe not
it might seem completely reasonable to
them mob accuses villager of witchcraft
villager denies it because which is
always deny it
prove you're not a witch they scream the
witch can't proving beyond a doubt that
she is in fact a witch to the stick she
goes Chris Coons would understand this
reasoning Koons is a Democrat from
Delaware and a member of the Senate
Judiciary Committee he's been making the
same case about Brett Kavanaugh in
public recently watch him explain it it
is judge Cavanaugh who is seeking a
lifetime appointment to the Supreme
Court and who I think now bears the
burden of disproving these allegations
rather than dr. Ford and miss Ramirez so
even those of you who are absolutely
dead certain that Brett Kavanaugh is
guilty as hell because you saw it on CNN
would have to admit that this does put
him in a tough spot
the rest of us assume the Constitution
guarantees us the presumption of
innocence when were accused Brett
Kavanaugh no longer has that protection
it's up to him to clear his own name he
can either figure out how to prove that
Christine Ford's foggy 36 year old
memories are wrong or his daughters can
grow up learning about how their dad is
a sex offender that's his choice so what
does he do next how do you disprove an
accuser who can't even tell you when or
where you supposedly committed the crime
well the FBI of course Democrats are
demanding that Kavanagh called down yet
another FBI investigation on himself yes
he has submitted to half a dozen federal
background checks already but Democrats
one another that's the only way he can
show he is innocent of these charges
various dumb people on television agree
with
this they nod their heads in unison but
would that really work is that the
purpose of FBI investigations Joe Biden
doesn't think so
keep in mind that Biden is both an
attorney and the former chairman of the
Senate Judiciary Committee watch this
the next person refers to an FBI report
as being worth anything obviously
doesn't understand anything
FBI explicitly does not in this or any
other case reach a conclusion period
period okay we fooled you again that is
Joe Biden from the 1991 Clarence Thomas
hearings
Biden was on the other side of the
debate then so naturally he had
completely different views from the ones
he holds today what hasn't changed are
the inherent limits of an FBI
investigation Democrats know that of
course but so what proving or disproving
a recovered memory is not the point the
point is destroying Brett Kavanaugh it's
worth saying that most Democrats in
Washington don't really hate Cavanaugh
personally he's hardly an abrasive
character as you learned if you watched
his interview with Martha last night
there's nothing personal about any of
this Cavanaugh stands between the
Democratic Party and the power it seeks
he is in the way he must be crushed in
this case along with his wife and his
two little girls sorry that's the cost
of winning no omelets without some
broken eggs the problem is that outside
party headquarters in DC people out
there don't understand this when they
hear a US Senator call Brett Kavanaugh a
sex criminal they believe it why
wouldn't they believe it because that's
the other thing that never changes ever
human nature there's a mob instinct in
people a gut-level desire to worship the
powerful and hurt the unpopular it's
always there in every population in
every country from the beginning of time
until now wise leaders know that wise
leaders fear that they try to keep it
contained they never stoke the mob
instinct once Unleashed there is no
controlling where a mob winds up or who
it destroys you can tell a mob is
building by the way people start talking
like this
I think there's a compromise here and
hear me out on this so Cavanaugh gets
confirmed the Supreme Court okay well in
return we get to cut that pesky penis of
his off in front of everyone so that's
where we are
castration medieval moments call for
medieval remedies and this is definitely
a medieval moment